uh hey we got a special guest on the
podcast right now Lefty Gunplay hey it's
the Gun Man famous gang banger OTR
boning Superstar right here tapping in
with ble Kevin man had to come run it up
venture to say He's the hottest rapper
in LA right now best I wouldn't say
hottest rapper in LA I say hottest
rapper in the uh for the Mexicans you
know nah see I don't even want to say
that cuz I feel like you got motion like
I'm not talking about just Mexicans cuz
that's boxing you wi I keep it real
there's some blacks that are way better
than me I'm talking about you're on fire
right now though no that's cool but n
I'm keeping the gas going let's run it
let's run it I want to be the best in
all California at the end of the day and
that's what I say and I keep it G like
yeah I'm the hardest essay I want to be
the hardest in California period you
know what I'm saying and like uh there's
some blacks that are really really hard
just doing unnatural like me but that's
why I'm working hard and uh it just
comes out all little do people know that
my new like a lot of my songs I
freestyle like 90% of them I just on the
first try just so that's your like
process of writing you don't write you
just off the to good I'm just good at it
just really good at rapping yeah put 100
Bands on the table for whoever thinks
they could get saay rapper thinks they
could get more views than me I'll put
the money on the table 20 bands 20 bands
right now we post tomorrow night and uh
or you post today and try to beat the
Gul start from scratch Lefty Gunplay but
you're probably going to get discouraged
after seeing the numbers so like I'll
put 20 bands on any essay rapper they
could do better than me I think I'm the
best like I really think I I really
would put 20,000 I'm not capping take
the 20 bands I'm not capping I'm the
best I'm going win the 20 bands back
like dog there's nobody you're not going
to [__] me over we go to the same room
nobody buy no followers nothing dog post
the same day boom you post whatever you
want I'm going post whatever I want I'll
post talking and get more views than you
iest set like it's just like that why
saw you just challenged uh Swifty do
$100,000 was it a song battle or what is
what is that who Swifty blue I don't
know that fool you know Swifty blue he
was the boy dog you know what I'm saying
hey he's the homie man I [__] with
Swifty Swifty is my dog you know I don't
[__] with him no more dog like he just
like he's cool dog we used to be boys
but you know what I'm saying [__]
changes dog friends switch up friends
switch up in real life [__] changes rap
stupid [__] rap just just like you know
he was the boy you know what I'm saying
I come in loyal you can't be loyal in
this in this game like just [__] like
that like I got carried away but like he
started it [__] him on say [__] him he
started it dog like you know what I'm
saying I used to rap grimy though you
can edit it I used to rap grimy Rec CU
he was the boy he was the boy it's just
I don't want anything to do with it I'm
going leave it at that well I think that
uh the productive way of solving just
give him his attention real quick no no
no I want to say give him his attention
I I want to tell you that the productive
way of solving any sort of issues is a
song challenge like you challenge for
100 that's a that's a way you solve
issues that's a peaceful way of doing it
whoever gets more views [__] wins and
you stop rapping but see that's how [__]
should be settled between artists kany
Street it's a competition it's music hey
Tri I don't want I'm not saying I'm I'm
I'm smoke you know I'm just saying know
I'm saying but that I think that that
was a dope that's a way you settle
things right yeah [__] him he ain't
going to take it though he going to take
it but he said I copied him I copied you
my boy you I am nothing like you dog
like I'm a [__] fool dog like I never
copied anything about you dog you hard I
know some of his songs but I never
copied him I don't think I rap like him
right I don't think he's better than me
I think you guys have different styles
for sure my boy I'm the best I came out
I've been out 30 days and look at me I'm
I'm I'm I'm better than all them dudes
like I'm better than a lot I'm home to a
lot but run it up I love the competition
run it up like how we going to be all
rapping and we can't play teams real
quick and see who what what better team
run it up put the money up gambling I
love to gamble like gamble like I got
money on this D do that sh sell out you
know what I'm saying it'll sell a lot of
money and I want to just I just want
everybody know like I am the best like I
I'm the best dog right now in the moment
when you were locked up did you hear
about um when greo and RJ took over the
novo and those those are like the legend
blacks no but I'm saying RJ no he greo
RJ Draco no greo RJ Draco comrad from
the ab um big sad 19 I got a song with
be sad um just people like Pac-Man The
Gun Man from OTR like you know what I'm
saying shout out to crib like X4 to ml
Lord like uh those are just dudes that
are just like really good at rapping
just do such nonchalant like shout to Zo
zo s's the best yeah zo's fire zo's my
boy and I'm just saying CU my friend
he's just like all around he got that it
Factor no I want to be more like zo I
really do the way he carries himself but
the ESS version I don't think I'll ever
be like that he's just that he's just
that guy man I'm just [__] stupid and
GH and just turned up and just like B
Sone just got it all in one package and
just carries it like humble just player
about it you know what I'm saying just
me like I'm just I just go with the flow
bazo so I'm just like every beat he gets
on his West Coast la
like he made some bangers right he hit
him with that underrated like I would
put money on him that he'll beat me with
the underrated that that song was it dog
that song took over La for a minute like
he did some legendary things with him I
got songs with Zama yeah like I talk to
him every day I'm on his page right now
like that's the homie he's like my
friend yeah I don't never put him in a
competition cuz he's already like that's
my boy already like he's just like man I
throw him first every time on the set
next how I was going to say uh how much
of like you honing your rap skills
happened while you were incarcerated or
were you rapping prior to you getting
locked up when you were 18 like cuz
you're really good at rapping you're not
like you know like you really are dope
were you were you like rapping a lot in
jail like I freest my [__] but that's
what I'm saying like that you you you're
really good at that so I'm assuming
where you getting your reps up while you
were in in in prison like just rapping
in yeah but I ran out of those songs
ASAP so to every whoever wants to rap
like don't use those first raps on like
the worst beat when you get out your
your best bangers don't use them on a
beat that you didn't [__] [__] fully
investing that you didn't write it too
cuz if you're in jail I wrote no I write
raps in jail with my head without a beat
without a beat or I remember a song on
the radio like like the and it be in
your head it'll be in my head I could
remember real
[__] be
like up in this [__] and I'mma knock
out call me left the gun plate I don't
[__] with dropouts so just I'll write it
in there and I'll make it and I'll just
go back and forward it's just crazy in
the writing process writing a song it's
just I wrote all my songs and uh I
memorized them after the first try but
there's these one songs like you write
in their bangers and when you get stuck
on a rap song If you ever made a rap
song and you don't buy your stuff you
make a rap song when you get stuck you
get stuck forever huh cash you get stuck
huh when you get stuck writing a song
you get stuck forever you never get past
that being stuck part huh you're so
stuck you erase it like a thousand times
with a certain song that's why I
freestyle just off the top cuz the first
one's the best one not anybody can do
that anymore either man that freestyle
[__] is a real gift it's like throw me
on theer they're going to throw me on
the ti
yeah I'm going to go against the best
uh no I'm going to win it I'm not going
to be part of it we're going to win it
La lefty gun play is it a competition
it's a competition why would you want to
lose the dard cipher I didn't I didn't
know I thought it was just everybody was
rapping n hell no they pick a winner do
they yeah did you see the little white
dude who who did it a little SE though I
se what tutu G won it from OT and he
beat M for uh shout out CH so and K bans
and and you know Tut G in San Diego one
that's for OTR I seen that one how did
you uh that's one of my favorite videos
Man shout out shout out 22 G F man that
song Hard it's a repeat you got to look
it up on the dard cipher it's called 22
G F dard Cipher or for you heard 4 L he
hard too I was going to get a feature
with him he hard to he those guys could
sing man both of them man one's black
one's like Filipino essay I don't know
what he he he one's black one's like you
know and they're both the best singers
ever I remember asking him like hey man
how do you learn how of s on 22 G he's
just like I just [__] shoot
it hey I thought I was in trouble he's
all like I asked G I told him what's up
man at the little weirdo concert I
walked up to him before i s with OTR I
said man you sing hard man and I'm
serious I'm just like you got any tips
for how to sing better and he's just
like I just do that [__] fool I'm just
like what the [__] like damn like that's
a lefty answer but it was just like he
was just cocky like I just do it and
it's just true you just do it you can
look up on Google don't and find CHT but
if you know how to sing your talented
you know how to sing dog you know what
I'm saying I want I want to I want to
sing I I want to sing and I just think
that's say the flowing gang [__] and it
just so you're going to start singing
eventually I been singing if you don't
pay